Bran Stark: The Kingdom of the North,
the Kingdom of the Mountain and the Vale,
the Iron Islands, the Kingdom of the Rock, the
Kingdom of the Reach, the Stormlands, and Dorne.
These regions had been established by
the First Men thousands of years before,
in the Age of Heroes.
One hero of this fabled age was Bran
the Builder. Bran raised the Wall and built the
stronghold of Winterfell, establishing House Stark
and reigning as the first King in the North.
Other legends tell of the Grey King in the Iron
Islands. Grey King took a mermaid to wife
and defeated Nagga, the first sea dragon.
House Greyjoy of Pyke, the current rulers
of the region, claim to descend from him.
House Casterly ruled the gold-rich Westerlands
from their mighty seat of Casterly Rock.
But their lands and power were swindled
from them by the legendary trickster,
Lann the Clever. The noble House of Lannister
is said to have descended from him.
The verdant and fertile lands of the Reach were
first ruled by House Gardener. Its founder,
known as Garth Greenhand, wore a crown of
flowers and vines. He ruled from Highgarden
as the first King of the Reach and was said
to have made the land bloom. Many noble houses
trace their bloodlines back to him, including
the current lords of Highgarden, House Tyrell.
In the Stormlands, according to ballads
of the age, a warrior named Durran fell
in love with Elenei, whose father was God of
the Sea, and mother was Goddess of the Wind.
She gave her maidenhead to him,
committing herself to a mortal life.
Enraged, her parents called
upon the winds and waters,
destroying Durran's bayside keep and wiping out
his wedding gift. Durran declared war on the gods
and rebuilt his keep, which was also destroyed.
Four more castles he raised, each stronger than
the last. All fell to the power of the gods. But
Durran's seventh castle, Storm's End, withstood
the gods' rage. Durran became known as Durran
Godsgrief and reigned as the first Storm King.
There are countless other tales from the Age
of Heroes, too many to count. These histories
weren't recorded in a book but passed down from
generation to generation through story and song.
And while some of them may be dismissed
as fairy tales, every one of the
Seven Kingdoms is defined by them.
The Starks of Winterfell trace their
descent to the First Men in the Age of Heroes.
The family's founder was Brandon the Builder who,
in the aftermath of the Long Night,
helped establish the Night's Watch.
Legend has it, he enlisted the aid of giants
and the powerful magic of the Children of
the Forest to raise the mighty Wall, which
has protected the realm for generations.
He went on to build the
ancestral seat of Winterfell
and reigned as the first King in the North.
Robb Stark: The Starks reigned as kings for
thousands of years, even withstanding the invasion
of the Andals. As the southern kingdoms fell,
and the Children were driven away,
the North stood strong, maintaining
its religious customs and its way of life.
Jon Snow: As for the other great Northern houses,
the Starks brought them into the
fold during the Age of Heroes.
A Stark wrestled an ironborn for Bear
Island and gave it to the Mormonts.
A Stark granted a keep and land to a younger son,
Karlon, in return for putting down a rebellion.
His family then grew up into the Karstarks.
Starks fought the wildlings and their
Kings-Beyond-the-Wall beside the Umbers
of Last Hearth, thus earning their fealty.
Boltons. Back then, they were the bane of
the North. A few were even rumored to wear
their enemies' flayed skins as cloaks.
I've seen how the land stretches
much farther than any man knows
into the Land of Always Winter, where the
White Walkers came from during the Long Night.
After the First Men and the Children
of the Forest beat them back,
Brandon the Builder raised the Wall
and set up the Night's Watch to
guard the realms of men.
Sansa Stark: When Bran the
Builder raised Winterfell and founded our
line, we were vassals to the Barrow Kings,
who claimed descent from the First King
and thus dominion over all the First Men.
But after the Long Night, it was our house
who built the Wall and set the Night's Watch
to guard the realms of men whilst our king
sat in his barrow. My ancestors eventually
revolted, waging what singers call the
Thousand Years War to free our lands.
Other families joined us, recognizing that the
North is a cold and hard land and needed a king
who served its people before himself.
Finally, the last Barrow King bent the knee,
and House Stark became the Kings of Winter.
Tywin Lannister: We Lannisters claim our descent
from the Andal invaders and, through
the female bloodline, Lann the Clever.
According to the legend, Lann, using only
his wits, won Casterly Rock from the noble
house of Casterly during the Age of Heroes.
Jaime Lannister: According to legend, a huntsman
once tracked a lion that was terrorizing its
village all the way to its den. Though armed
with only a spear, the man managed to kill both
the lion and its mate, but spared the cubs. This
mercy so pleased the Old Gods that they sent a
shaft of sunlight deep into the cave, gleaming
off golden walls. The hunter became a miner
and built a ringfort to guard his new wealth.
Nobody ever asks what happened to the cubs. Maybe
the gods forgot about them, and they starved.
Maybe there never were any cubs or
lions or hunter, doesn't matter.
Someone found enough gold in that cave to buy
whatever truth he wanted, along with a castle that
he'd name after his new family. Casterly Rock.
The castle is sadly all that remains of
its namesake family, the Casterlys.
According to another legend, my ancestor
Lann the Clever, swindled the castle from them.
The most common story is that he found a hidden
cleft in the rock and snuck into the castle.
As night, he whispered threats into sleeping ears,
howled in the darkness, planted one brother's
treasures in the room of another, and so forth.
By the end of his games, the Casterlys believed
a demon was haunting their home and fled.
My brother prefers a different version. Lann the
Clever did find a secret entrance into the rock
but used it to have his way
with the Casterly maidens.
Eventually, the girls gave birth to golden-haired
bastards, and the Casterlys had no choice but to
accept their father into the family. In gratitude,
he changed the family name to honor himself,
and House Lannister was born.
Tywin Lannister: According to legend,
we trace their descent to Lann the Clever,
a trickster of the Dawn Age, who swindled
the Casterlys out of Casterly Rock, their ancient
castle. A childish story, but not without merit.
One, a mind can and should be
a weapon in a man's arsenal.
Two, Lann must've been clever enough
not to rely solely on his wits.
After all, where today is House Casterly?
Three, by keeping the Casterly name
on the castle, Lann reminded the world
of the price of getting in his way.
Catelyn Stark: The Arryns are direct
descendants of Andal invaders, who sailed across
the Narrow Sea and came ashore at the Fingers.
According to legend, Ser Artys Arryn, known as
"the Winged Knight," soared through the skies
atop a giant falcon, landing on
the peak of the highest mountain,
where he defeated the Griffin King in battle.
It was the Andals' first great victory over the
First Men. And Ser Artys was duly rewarded. He
was declared King of the Mountain and the Vale,
and the region renamed "the Vale of Arryn."
Robert Baratheon: The seat of House Baratheon
is Storm's End, a legendary keep
raised in the Age of Heroes.
It overlooks Shipbreaker Bay, where legend
has it that Durran, the first Storm King,
raised the keep with the aid of Bran the
Builder of House Stark, forging a centuries-long
connection with the Stormlands and the North.
Brienne of Tarth: Even without our weather,
we have more than earned our name in
strife. The first Storm King, Durran,
started his reign by declaring war on the gods
themselves. He loved the daughter of the sea god
and the wind goddess, but they forbade the union.
At their wedding, the gods unleashed their might,
pulling down his hold and killing all of
Durran's family and guests, though his
wife shielded him. Durran vowed to rebuild, and
when he did, the gods again destroyed his home.
His councilors begged him to retreat
inland, but he would not abandon his war.
Finally, with the council of the Children of
the Forest, or perhaps a young Bran the Builder,
Durran raised a seventh castle that, try as
they might and still do, the wind and sea
gods could not tear asunder. Durran took the name
Godsgrief and called his new home Storm's End.
Samwell Tarly: According to legend, House
Targaryen survived the Doom of Valyria thanks to
Daenys the Dreamer, who foresaw the calamity
and convinced her father to flee their homeland.
It could be true. The Targaryens
were always a bit more.